[Musique]
me faire rassemblement l'avait lavé de
l'a20 défilé d'abord le défilé carnaval
autour de bastérou à part la robe de sa
longue à mon histoire à tout maria tout
voté mitterrand
non monsieur marc camoletti aussi
essentielle dans un coin à l'ats péter
haas et son petit guitare tranquille
quoi bein c'est lui parce qu'on m'a pas
reconnue et après m'a plu autant devoir
lui après émettons gaillard que ça le
thème est à moi on va croiser ce
métier-là de la musique la rue de la
faute à moi à côté militant c'est à dire
que nous connaît que tout doute qu'il
tient toute notre héritage d'une bonne
bonne tonton ma tendance est si nous
bataille pas si ça va
montano et magna vivre magna doit que
tout le temps la guide à nous dans notre
vie soul bien parce que ces idées là on
espère que m'inspire de génération comme
utilisation à venir
[Musique]